you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
big boost to nuclear offshore wind and
solar lesso to onshore wind as the
government announces its new energy
plans
we want to have a security of supply we
want to live in a world where we're not
dependent on what russian policy is but
we have more control
over energy sources here in britain
but the opposition says the strategy
doesn't make sense
they have rejected the cheapest cleanest
most secure form of power which is on
short wind
and oil and gas will also play a role
but where does that leave net zero
ambitions
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
so the government's long-awaited energy
security strategy has finally been
published it was designed to secure
long-term energy supply in a new world
after russia's invasion of ukraine
well nuclear power is central to the new
vision solar and hydrogen will also be
boosted
offshore wind a favorite of the prime
minister gets an even more ambitious
target than it had previously
but political disagreement has meant the
cheaper and quicker onshore wind has
been put on the back burner for now our
business correspondent paul kelso
reports
thanit offshore wind farm was the
largest in the world when it was
commissioned it will be dwarfed in a
decade under government plans to
quadruple power capacity at sea
is that maintenance it's one of the crew
vessels yes investing in wind makes
sense for breezy britain but even the
industry thinks delivering is a
challenge
it's taking at the moment up to 10 years
to get a project from the drawing board
into operation and part of that half of
that time is consense
the government today have said they want
to get that down to a year that's a real
acceleration
this field produces 300 megawatts of
power hitting the 50 gigawatt target
will need 150 times more
the government wants there to be enough
of these to power every home in the
country by 2030 and on days like today
wind is an abundant commodity but to
underwrite this bet on renewables we'll
still need fossil fuels there'll be new
north sea oil and gas licenses and a
massive investment in nuclear power and
none of this will bring down bills in
the short term
tell me what you want me to do harriet
okay come on so we've currently got one
pump in service
the prime minister was at the new
hinckley point nuclear reactor to
emphasize his faith in a still
contentious technology promising to
approve the equivalent of eight more in
as many years though not how to pay for
them
this is about tackling some of the uh
the mistakes of of the past and making
sure that we are set well for the future
we're no longer subject to uh we'll
never again subject to the the vagaries
of the uh global oil or gas price we
can't be subject to blackmail as it were
from
people such as vladimir putin
onshore wind is the fastest cheapest
route to renewable energy but new
developments will remain blocked with
few exceptions following pressure from
conservative mps
this is where the pump is in here
the best way for consumers to cut bills
and emissions is to cut consumption with
new technology like air source heat
pumps
yeah no got no gas bills to worry about
and i believe they've gone a lot more up
a lot so i know that
so yeah i'm saving up for me all of
these now
there was no new money for this or
improving insulation in britain's aging
housing stock
it's all about electrification so
whether it's from nuclear or offshore
wind or onshore wind or solar panels
we've got to electrify society it's the
way we escape the way we make this the
last fossil fuel crisis the uk has to
suffer
this strategy was only planned after the
invasion of ukraine exposed european
reliance on russian gas a short-term
response to changing political weather
now has to stand the test of time paul
kelso sky news in kent
so what is the plan how does it help
consumers but also how compatible is it
with our long-term climate goals here's
our science correspondent thomas more
the energy strategy sets a goal for 95
percent of british electricity to be low
carbon by 2030 we are way off that now
this is a snapshot of how we were
generating power at noon on thursday
only 70 was zero carbon with 45
coming from wind on a breezy day so
what's the plan well wind will provide
the biggest share of generating capacity
with 50 gigawatts by the end of the
decade that's up from 25 now and most of
the new turbines will be offshore
nuclear will also increase with up to
eight reactors being built by 2030
providing 24 gigawatts by 2050 that's
out from less than nine from the six
existing plants most of which is due to
be shut down soon the government wants
to increase solar too at the moment the
sun produces 14 gigawatts of uk
electricity and the government wants to
raise that by up to five times
more north sea oil and gas is also in
the plan with a new round of licenses
being issued this summer so does the
strategy deliver well there are three
tests first does it replace the energy
we get from russia that's four percent
of uk gas imports and 13 of oil imports
well not anytime soon there's nothing in
the strategy about reducing energy
demand the quickest way of having an
impact after the fukushima accident
japan replaced half its nuclear capacity
by reducing electricity consumption and
shifting use away from peak times it
works
by comparison a new solar farm can take
a year to get through planning and
construction
new nuclear reactors are likely to take
a decade a new north sea gas fields
proposed earlier this year won't come on
stream until 2028 the second test is
whether the strategy reduces energy
bills well yes but not for several years
wind and solar now cost below 50 pounds
per megawatt hour nuclear costs almost
twice as much upwards of 90 but gas
right now is more than 200 and that's
driving up our bills drilling for more
won't make a difference the shift to
renewables will
and the final test does the strategy
deliver on net zero the accelerated
transition to zero carbon electricity
will help but drilling for more oil and
gas has angered green campaigners and
there's nothing about improving
insulation of uk houses which leak heat
so on all three tests it seems doubtful
that the energy strategy does enough
fast enough
so how much political disagreement has
there been over this strategy john craig
is our chief political correspondent
this strategy reveals just how much
disagreement there is both on the
conservative back benches and indeed in
boris johnson's cabinet now the real
political significance of this strategy
unveiled by the prime minister today is
not what's in it but what isn't in it
and that reveals just how much there's
been a battle inside the cabinet uh
between
the business department led by
quasi-quattan and the treasury and
indeed number 10. the big thing that's
missing from this strategy is a big
development on onshore wind now
quasi-quatting wanted a big expansion
and
document suggests that he called for
that he also called for uh for a
relaxation of planning laws but that has
come up up against opposition from uh
back benchers and indeed some cabinet
ministers we know that jacob reese mogg
has spoken out against uh against uh
more onshore wind on sophie ridge on
sunday are here on sky news uh the
transport secretary grant shaps
described wind onshore wind farms as
eyesores and the new chief whip of the
conservative party in the government
chris heaton harris is the same mp who
back in 2014 led a huge campaign against
onshore wind when david cameron was
prime minister
so that big expansion is missing other
things that are missing well um energy
efficiency help for home insulation we
know that uh the business department
also wanted more money from the treasury
for people to help with home insulation
and energy efficiency at home but the
chancellor said no we're spending enough
on that already thirdly
there's a and andrea ledson the former
cabinet minister said on sky news today
there wasn't enough on helping people
their short-term problems with their
bills so the prime minister looks like a
prisoner of his party and the cabinet
and it's what's missing from this that's
significant rather than what's in it
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and a group of eu
countries have said the block should
speed up negotiations on new climate
change policies as they seek to end
reliance on russian energy a statement
led by denmark and signed by 11
countries including germany and spain
says any delay in moving ahead with the
green transition will only prolong
energy dependence on russia the eu has
said it wants to end imports of russian
oil and gas by 2027.
flash floods hit australia's east coast
today with sydney receiving nearly a
month's rainfall overnight into thursday
forcing residents to evacuate
sydney has received more than 48 inches
of rain so far this year that's more
than its normal annual rainfall
three intense weather systems have hit
the region in six weeks a result of the
la nina weather phenomenon and experts
believe climate change
conservationists are warning that the
current cold weather could hit frogs
butterflies and bees that have emerged
early due to a mild winter the woodland
trust says april's extended cold snap
could mean insects are amongst animals
that will struggle to survive meaning
tree species such as willow and black
thorn which are now flowering may not
thrive this year the charity warned
birds that have already started nesting
and frogs born could also be affected
now as we've heard while the central
push of the energy strategy is on
nuclear and renewable energy
fossil fuels will also be playing a
significant role in providing our energy
for many years in the future so the oil
and gas companies must be pretty happy
with the plans well earlier i spoke to
deidre michie she's chief executive of
offshore energies uk the body which
represents the oil and gas companies
operating in the north sea
i think we do welcome it because it does
focus on reducing our
need for imports over the years and you
know encouraging a move a faster move to
net zero so part of what we've been
doing as a sector is really trying to
reinforce that the sector does have a
positive role in supporting security of
energy supply but also underpinning the
energy transition because a lot of our
members are delivering oil and gas but
they're also driving forward uh offshore
wind carbon capture and storage and
hydrogen so it's a good combination and
yes we do welcome it
and yet the message from the
international energy agency also from
the big ipcc report this week has been
that there should be no new fossil fuel
projects if we're going to avoid the
worst effects of climate change so this
decision by the government today flies
in the face of that it's really not
compatible with that message and doesn't
it risk us missing our net zero target
no absolutely not you know our are we're
very clear that our contribution
to the security of supply of the uk
is very much linked to how much oil and
gas the uk will continue to need albeit
on a reducing basis over the coming
years and so we believe that for as long
as we need oil and gas it's far better
and we will have a lower emissions
footprint for us to
produce it here and support our own
indigenous industry rather than having
to import it from abroad where we have
no control over our missions and
actually the import of that product will
actually increase the amount of
emissions that are that are being you
know
made up by the world so actually
focusing and having our own independent
um energies like that is actually a
positive rather than a negative step
as you know there's been a lot of
concern about people's rising energy
bills but producing more oil and gas
from the north sea even though it's from
this country it's going to have no
impact on our bills is it because it's
all fed into
the global energy market
yeah no absolutely and that's that is a
challenge so this this is very much
looking to see what we can do in the in
the longer term in the short term we are
facing uh quite considerable uh
challenges and consumers and businesses
are as you say because of the the
challenges that that there are around
the the commodity prices because as you
say they are part of a global market so
yeah
this won't this won't help unlock
anything in the short term but in the
long or the near to longer term it
should start to make a difference
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by climate justice activist michaela
loach and mike berners-lee author
academic and carbon footprinting expert
and we'll be discussing this
government's energy security strategy do
they have their priorities right and
what have happened to net zero
[Music]
it was an unbelievable trip i mean we
were out there for nearly a month um
completely off-grid for two weeks so
it's one of the most remote mountains in
the himalayas so there's no signal wi-fi
as you can imagine which was a pretty
special process in itself just us and
the porters and sherpas the nepali team
intense for two weeks
on the actual mountain
the climbing period um
was difficult to say the least because
no one's been on that mountain for over
two years um it's a pretty
full-on seventh thousand meter mountain
and and it goes over a lot of glaciers
so um the crevasse fields have moved
quite a lot in those two years so a lot
of the time we were having to feel our
way
through it um we ended up with a 1200
meter summit day vertical meter summit
day which um which is a lot because camp
3 wasn't able to be set up and we
actually ended up getting to about 6 800
meters
which is a new world record for for
someone with a
spinal cord injury i was professional
player before it was very difficult for
me
losing the ability to move and um i was
a physical person and my identity was
wrapped up in that and you know my
spinal cord injury still affects me
greatly all the weakness through my left
side i have underlying
um conditions sort of bladder bowel
temperature regulation spasms all of
these things that aren't very conducive
to climbing mountains but i got to the
point where
i was just constantly being told what i
couldn't do anymore
and i kind of got i had enough of that
and i just started to explore what i
could do and it started off by hobbling
up small hills and it's transpired into
climbing bigger mountains but
hopefully we can represent i want to
represent the the entire spinal cord
injury community but not just them
anyone with physical limitations to the
outdoors because i realize how lucky i
am to even be in that position to to
take on a mountain like that so many
people aren't every injury is different
but hopefully by doing what we're doing
we can encourage more people to maybe
break out of the
narrative that they're being given being
told they can't do things and go and
find out for themselves so
i set up a charity to do exactly that to
help other people who are going through
trauma use the mountains use the
outdoors to encourage them to do that
call millimeters to mountains just hope
that other people who go through trauma
and life-changing accidents or incidents
can start to see the brightness on the
other side and stop looking at things
they can't do and start dreaming about
the things they can and take that first
step towards um towards a new life
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate justice activist michaela loach
and mike berners-lee from the university
of lancaster an expert in carbon
footprinting so very good to see you
both good evening
so the long-awaited and somewhat delayed
energy strategy is here so have the
government got their priorities right
my bonus lead to you first of all so the
government is talking about
up to 95 of the uk's electricity uh
coming from low carbon sources possibly
by 2030 so good news
well it sounds like good news but
they've made
some big mistakes in this strategy so
the biggest is probably just not putting
the emphasis on demand management that
uh was so important
there's no room at all for new uh
for new oil and gas uh extraction and
they missed a trick uh on as david
miliband and others have pointed out on
the onshore wind as well it would be
much better to put the emphasis on
onshore wind which comes much quicker
and cheaper rather than
okay michaela do you agree with that
because boris johnson says this is about
tackling the mistakes of the past and
making sure that we're set for the
future
he would point out
you know
much more offshore wind more solar more
hydrogen more nuclear they would say
it's very green
i mean i think we need to be clear that
this um strategy is nothing short than
their scandalous failure and what they
are doing what this government is doing
is sacrificing many ordinary people all
of our futures and our presence for
profit we are currently experiencing two
crises we're having this energy
affordability crisis where 2.5 million
households with children were plunged
into fuel poverty overnight and we have
this climate crisis which the ipcc the
internet governmental panel on climate
change said this week that it's their
last warning to us that we have to
tackle it and yet we're seeing a
strategy that is pushing for more oil
and gas is pushing for the exact thing
that's caused this crisis and it's
completely ridiculous for boys johnson
to say that this is um amending the
mistakes of the past when all this is
doing is continuing those mistakes and
making them even worse and we should all
be really really angry about it and we
should all act to try and change this
because it's completely scandalous okay
let's pick up the issue about oil and
gas with you mike shall we because there
are more renewables but as mckayla was
hitting there more fossil fuels as well
because there will be more north sea oil
and gas
does that make sense though given that
we're phasing out russian oil and gas to
replace it domestically the government
would argue that that's actually
slightly greener than importing it and
we do need a managed transition don't we
they would say
before we get all these renewables on
stream
it's a false choice the way through all
this is to put a lot more emphasis on
demand reduction i mean whether you care
about
reigning in putin or
fuel poverty uh or
climate or you know from all of those
agendas or just having an efficient
economy
helping people in this country to live
well with far less energy demand is uh
is you know is is the one thing that
makes everything else work is this it's
the single most important place to be
putting the pressure at the moment
there's no excuse at all for
new oil and gas
in absolute in direct contradiction to
what the ipcc is saying
and you've both touched on this issue of
reducing demand the government said this
is all about making sure that we've got
supply sorted for the future but what
about demand a lot of people
disappointed there wasn't more to make
it cheaper and easier for us all to
insulate our houses for example the hope
being that we would use less energy
and and keep warm
michaela what do you think of that i
mean the government might say we're
spending so much money we haven't got
there's not a bottomless pit of cash
especially post pandemic
well i think it's just really
disappointing that within this um
strategy there was no inclusion of
insulation when a survey is recently
shown that 80 of brits want installation
to happen they want their homes
insulated and that's something that is
cheaper and easier to do retrofitting
homes is something that we really really
need to do and if we're not decreasing
the demand then all we're doing is
wasting huge amounts of energy and we're
going to be using more fossil fuels than
we need to and even more other energy we
need to be being more efficient and
there are so many things that we could
be able to do and it's ridiculous this
government to make out that they can't
do it or they don't have enough money to
do it because these things aren't even
that expensive to do and they would have
a real like quick impact on so many
people's lives today and they would
really impact this energy affordability
crisis and the climate crisis together
and they should be pursuing them and
it's only because they are in the
pockets of fossil fuel companies that
they are not pursuing these and we need
to be very very clear about that
let's move on to the issue of nuclear
shall we mike because the government's
been very keen to stress that it wants
to be a big um power as far as a nuclear
is concerned up to eight new plants
they're saying could be approved i mean
that is a green choice isn't it i mean i
know that some environmentalists are
divided on this but it but it's good as
far as emissions is concerned isn't it
well it's better than taking fossil fuel
more fossil fuel out of the north sea i
suppose you can argue but uh you know it
takes a long time to come on stream
it matters the timing with which we cut
our carbon emissions really really
matters onshore wind comes on um you
know 10 years earlier at least
and
uh it comes in at half the price so you
know if you're if you're comparing it
against onto your window absolutely made
the wrong choice but you know the demand
management side you we don't talk
anything like enough about reducing this
country's energy demand and you know if
we don't sort out our housing stock and
actually some of the things uh that we
need to do to retrofit our housing is
actually i think some of it is quite
expensive but you know what if we don't
do it it will hang around this country
and the people of this country forever
so you know we put it off and we put it
off and at some point expensive or not
we actually need to face up to it
otherwise we'll have a you know
fundamentally inefficient economy with
houses that are difficult to live in
that put people into fuel poverty and
end up being high carbon so we've gotta
we've got to take that one on mckenna
just to pick up the point that mike was
saying there about onshore wind
no doubting there's a big commitment to
offshore wind but is it understandable
that the government's more cautious
about onshore wind given that people
might not like the idea of having wind
farms
in their backyard if you like if they
don't
people are worried that agricultural
land might be but might be used to put
wind farms on as well is there a concern
about what the public might make of it
i think that people are way more
concerned about the fact that they have
huge energy bills currently and i think
that people in general are way more
concerned about the future that the
climate crisis would bring to us and the
present that's already impacting people
today and so i think we should be
prioritizing things that actually tackle
the real crisis people are facing like
seeing a wind turbine in close to your
home is not crisis whereas not being
able to pay your bills is one like
seeing a wind turbine close your home is
not a crisis but not being able to live
safely in the future is really one and i
think that we have an opportunity to
really tackle this crisis and that
requires us to pursue the kind of
solutions that are already available to
us we were really lucky that the ipcc
report this week actually gave us so
many of these solutions and we need to
be following them and not allowing this
government to instead distract us and
kind of insult our own intelligence by
making us um by kind of using their
green washing to trick us into thinking
that they're actually attacking this
crisis and when actually all that
they're doing is pursuing more and more
harmful practices instead okay michaela
mike really interesting to get your take
on it thanks very much indeed for
joining us today
thank you well that's it for today i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you